welcome to this video playing barracuda
and somewhat a weird way I mean written
spelt somewhat weird way I could play
the exchange will open signed I think
had probably never played that on video
why not yeah yeah that's definitely a
line black is supposed to be okay here
with Bishop e7
yeah that that cannot be bad either 92
93 I don't know i'm not an expert I've
got some experience on the black side of
course but in the general structure not
that particular position I guess yeah
black I should be able to play a 5 and
unless I go g4s that's too ambitious
maybe but let's try i can go g6 it can
probably blow up in my face pretty bad
lame that you fall over hmm okay h5 it's
also on okay 96-95 is his plan which
isn't bad either all night a4 also
possible
yeah neither for i mean if i take we've
got a very funny structure keep going
here
okay but this isn't that nice now for me
of the night coming to you for I have to
cover f3 and then 94 I mean f6 looks
like pretty bad weakness Oh does he have
some stuff like rook age to maybe look
age to King takes Knight g4 double check
and then night xe3 at then this kind of
thing maybe I was just hallucinating but
in general I don't mind the trade see
anyway so take now and 94 is not not
working here
not working yet I wonder if I do if I
want to trade everything here including
looks maybe almond certainly an easy way
to play let's still think it should
preserve a slight advantage as he's got
all those pawns on dark squares and we
both suffer from that doubled pawns and
what's this 94 I see placing even more
pawns on dark squares it's a bit strange
that's a bit strange mr. Barracuda okay
so he just about has it covered
okay I wonder ever I can't think I
should go be through here make it a bit
more difficult for him okay
c4 hmm
I wonder if I should go see for him if
he takes it and text that pawn I will
take care of six that should be good for
wine okay ticks ticks maybe Bishop b5
and then Knight b6 this is what I'm
worried about a little bit now I get in
c4
so you shooting form Bishop t4 here and
how to believe no I can take actually
should be good take in d3 on Bishop c4
and it doesn't have that many move Sam
absolutely wants to put all pawns on
dark squares just just like try to test
if the position is someone can hold that
or not or i can stain I can stand that
is the right right way to put it like
how badly can you place your pawns and
still not lose anyway I'll go to um II
for and 93 and then shrimp life-form
that's a big difference i can actually
go where form well black it's not able
to do something symbolize pawns i could
just do valued one thing I'm asking
myself is now not bad if you can like
night if 593 Knight takes e4 if you can
play some kind of crazy sacrifice and
but it should work no okay I have to one
thing is I mean it shouldn't be
checkmated now our King doesn't have
many squares night c 8 so now it takes
you five some there is no made if you
just goes back to the seven f4 will win
technically take it takes a while but
it's a win and a time money I'm
effectively pulling up now
I could have to g5 actually what is he
doing I don't get it and shooting
further for the sacrifices I guess hmm
yeah that is kind of interesting okay
let's be quick here mp3
that was close was really close black
for offense on time poor tough game but
I really tried to put all pawns on the
wrong color for some weird reason let's
let's look around here and white white
is always a bit more comfortable but and
it got too serious proportions only a
bit later I don't think he he had to
play stuff like this for example I was
also wondering about King g5 him wasn't
quite sure check this was one idea that
I had Chad cause of this side this this
line at this I believe that that should
win for white somehow the engine is
actually more straightforward it just
does this this directly going for the
for the majority there yeah that's
probably better but i was thinking I've
got lots of time and then to prepare but
there should be three years I'm pretty
useless actually yeah but I was just in
time with my own corn so that that
didn't work out we should have six was
those those moose ago cool
I mean nothing I'm difficult there at
the end but still kind of kind of static
to win like that okay thanks for
watching